all right who in the studio among uh
rocky ron
carlos has turned on the heater yeah oh
yeah
not yet oh rocky you're a holdout lois
you and ron both
yeah yeah we we broke down we broke yeah
the air is off at least all right so
some people
haven't turned on their heaters just yet
but right now is the perfect time to
make sure
yours is working properly mercedes
talked to an expert
to get all the details take a look
november is the time that las vegas will
usually turn on their heaters for the
first time and you want to make sure the
air quality in your home is great
donovan rowe general manager of one hour
air conditioning and heating of las
vegas is here to help first of all
donovan
talk to us about air quality products
what do they do
for our home
so you know your home is very well
insulated nowadays
a lot of people when it gets cold or hot
they're not going to have their windows
or doors open so you're basically
circulating the same air
over and over so there are products out
there that can make
the air inside your home cleaner fresher
and healthier
can you tell us about some of those
products that
that you have that we can get to help
our homes yeah i mean when you talk
about
indoor air quality you know outside you
have mother nature
that cleans the air inside you don't
have that so
inside your home we can put many
different products from
electronic air cleaners to uv energy
sanitation modules that can help
duplicate
what mother nature does but it can do it
inside your home and it connects to your
central air conditioning and heating
system so
you know if you go to like the cdc
they'll tell you
there's three different levels of things
that can be in your home
now these uv sterilization modules
you're talking about is that
is that using light in order to to clean
the air
correct here's a little example of one a
a lamp it's basically a lamp right
the sun produces uv energy and that's
what these lamps do they produce
different wavelengths of uv energy
to replicate what the sun does but it
does it inside your central air
conditioning system to treat
and neutralize that air you're running a
promotion right now around
indoor quality can you tell us more
about that we're doing
what we call a clean air bundle so if
you're a brand new customer to one hour
you can call and get a clean air bundle
and what it is you get the uv lamp
here and you get that tune up on your
heater
for 129. that sounds like a great
deal thank you so much if you need more
information
on that just call them at 702-996-3304
what what great information donovan
thank you you can also find them online
one hour heat and air.com take advantage
of their 129
clean air bundle which includes the
heating tune-up and uv
air purification system